et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
riverdt bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes député renaissance
de lois anciens mini c'est vous qui avez
porté la réforme des retraites de 2010
on va bien sur longuement parler de
cette réforme des retraites on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour un
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Stéphane
Vernet de westfrance bonjour Stéphane
bonjour bonjour
avec les parlementaires de la majorité
pour préparer la commission mixte
paritaire à laquelle vous allez
participer que vous aviez les Abed born
cannelle motor
almodorde c'était de regarder les
différents sujets qui restaient ouvert
il y en a beaucoup pour la pour la CMP
et d'échanger d'échanger les positions
une réunion sérieuse solide détendue
détendu je note que il n'y avait pas de
tension c'est très important c'est
contradictoire avec ce que j'entends par
ailleurs
de revenir évidemment sur le fond
détendu ça veut dire qu'il y a pas
d'inquiétude de la part de la première
ministre sur l'issue de cette
députés les sénateurs aussi de la
majorité très très oui il y avait pas de
voyelles c'est une réunion de travail
classique et elle était bien préparée
c'est à peu près les positions que
l'assemblée va défendre les positions
que le Sénat va défendre et puis je
pense qu'on se n'arrivera un accord en
tout cas je l'espère évidemment et tout
le monde l'espère qu'il y aura une CMP
comme on dit positive après le texte oui
je crois
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ils ont
certitude sont évidemment partout dans
ce bas monde mais je pense qu'il y a de
très très grandes chances que cette CMP
soit positive et qu'elle fasse un
travail que n'a pas pu faire en réalité
l'assemblée c'est-à-dire un travail
serein
sans pression et que le faire avec nos
nos amis sénateurs le Parisien nous
apprend que le chef de l'État Emmanuel
Macron a passé une tête dans cette
réunion est-ce que vous confirmez
qu'est-ce que il était détendu lui aussi
alors j'ai pas vu de tête du président
de la République où j'étais peut-être
pas dans la bonne réunion on a confirmé
qu'il est intervenu ou pas dans cette
réunion
pas dans cette réunion là je ne crois
pas enfin voilà
il était dans la Réunion
d'après Alex hello n'était pas
visiblement Elisabeth band on va rentrer
dans le détail évidemment mais qu'est-ce
qu'elle vous a demandé est-ce qu'elle
vous a demandé d'être souple avec les
républicains parce que l'objectif c'est
vraiment que cette commission
d'expéritaire soit conclusive ou est-ce
qu'elle vous a demandé de ne rien hacher
sur les positions de la majorité non
c'est pas comme ça c'est qu'on regarde
chaque sujet enfin on peut les il y
avait un articles donc il y a beaucoup
de sujets il y a des sujets on voit bien
on essaie de mesurer la priorité la
priorité des uns et des autres il faut
évidemment un vote des républicains tout
le monde l'a bien compris on connaît les
priorités des républicains bien au Sénat
on les connaît à peu près à l'Assemblée
nationale il faut bien vérifier qu'elles
sont possibles qu'elles sont d'abord
finançables aussi puisque c'est
nécessairement des priorités qui sont
coûteuses et c'est ça les sujets et où
sont les lignes rouges vous savez il
faut les classer vers priorité il y a
des choses auxquelles on tient mais on
voit bien qu'il faut un compromis on
n'est pas les abandonner ah je vais pas
du tout rentrer dans le fond de la
discussion de la CMP elle est demain les
deux rapporteurs des deux commission des
affaires sociales se réunissent c'était
réuni hier je crois se réunissent sans
doute encore aujourd'hui comme il se
doit pour balayer le texte je peux
absolument pas vous en parler mais
est-ce qu'il y a des points sur lesquels
vous êtes prêt à lâcher aux républicains
des choses qui ont été votées
au Sénat et sur lesquels vous allez dire
oui on pense par exemple à la sur côte
pour les maires de famille
a été voté avec un avis favorable du
Gouvernement ça donne quand même une
indication avec un avis favorable au
préalable du gouvernement donc il y a
beaucoup de sujets sur les droits
familiaux sur effectivement cette
surcote mais cette surcote on la connait
bien c'est un sujet dont on a parlé à
l'Assemblée j'en ai même parlé avant le
texte lui-même on a répondu à de
nombreuses questions là-dessus bon donc
tout ça tout ça va faire une vraie
synthèse et d'une synthèse qui permettra
l'équilibre financier du texte puisque
c'est très important à 2030 et puis de
d'ouvrir encore plus le caractère juste
de
[Musique]
pour 2030 pour 2030 on est en 2023 et
peut se passer beaucoup de choses et
d'ailleurs les calculs des mesures sont
soumis et sont faites très très
sérieusement mais ils peuvent évolués
puisque sont par principe des des
prévisions donc on verra bien donc il
faut être très prudent là-dessus et
l'objectif alors total du de la première
ministre ça va être soit et du
gouvernement mais aussi de la majorité
c'est de je pense que les républicains
aussi d'ailleurs ils sont très sensibles
au moins la républicain qui qui voteront
ce texte c'est que ce texte il doit
assurer d'une d'un équilibre financier à
2000-2030 et par exemple il y a encore
une question c'est la question des
carrières longues qui est encore en
débat et qui fait d'ailleurs aussi
divergents non seulement entre les
républicains de l'assemblée du Sénat
mais aussi au sein de la majorité
puisque c'est quelque chose qui est
porté par horizon aussi est-ce que ça
c'est une question qui doit se poser que
toutes les Français dans un dispositif
de carrière longue ne travaille pas
au-delà de 43 ans
c'est une question qui peut se poser
c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui je juge je
le remarque parce que tout d'un coup les
yeux les beaucoup ont ouvert les yeux
les premiers propagandises que
d'ailleurs de cette idée de savais même
pas que c'était pas déjà le cas donc
donc
45 + 1 + 2 oui on a plus une année plus
de jusqu'à deux années de plus et au
fond quand même c'est des personnes qui
parlent plutôt elles partent plutôt même
si elle travaille un peu plus longtemps
d'ailleurs elles ont commenté plus
longtemps font elles vont travailler
plus de trimestres ou plus d'années mais
elles vont partir en âge bien plus tôt
que les autres personnes c'est un débat
qui a été très confus parce que c'est
très confus j'ai essayé c'est un peu
technique il y a des bornes il y a des
il y a des on peut lisser enfin bon on
verra bien le texte sur lequel nous
tombons d'accord au moment de au moment
de
la société voté par les sénateurs c'est
à dire que ils ont voté ce que
d'ailleurs madame borne avait indiqué à
l'Assemblée nationale si l'extension
à l'âge jusqu'à la 21e année c'est à
dire jusqu'à juste avant l'âge de 21 ans
des carrières en discuter d'ailleurs de
savoir si c'est vraiment une carrière
longue mais bon admettons que ce soit
quelque chose qui était ça a été voté
par les sénateurs donc on part de cette
base il y a une revendication de
notamment d'Olivier Marleix pour les
pour les républicains qui est un petit
peu différente pas beaucoup mais un peu
différente donc un peu plus coûteuse et
donc et d'horizon et donc nous en
discuterons en commission mixte
paritaire
que sur les carrières longues la CMP
peut encore changer des choses sur les
carrières longues la CMP mais la CMP
elle peut changer partout donc elle peut
changer des choses là où c'est important
si c'est un lieu de conciliation et si
ça permet un compromis qui a un moment
donné permet aussi de voter un texte
vous savez vous des républicains je dis
après midi va aussi beaucoup dépendre de
ce sujet principal des commissions
mixtes paritaires c'est l'obtention de
compromis compromis c'est un terme
négatif ou positif il est négatif quand
il reste plus grand chose il est positif
quand il reste d'abord un texte quand il
reste l'objectif de ce texte et quand ce
texte il est solide et le texte qui sera
issu de la CMP ce sera obligatoirement
un texte solide et un texte un test un
texte équilibré financièrement c'est
c'est bien de cela
c'est aussi un message
et notamment LR à l'Assemblée autour une
position un peu différente pas tellement
différente mais un peu différente de
celle du Sénat parmi parmi les points
qui vont devoir être discutés et qui
pourraient faire l'objet d'un compromis
ou pas il y a le CDI senior par exemple
est-ce que ça c'est quelque chose que
vous pensez intéressant fondamental au
cœur de ces négociations ou pas et je
vous ai dit que j'allais pas prendre
tous les sujets Lisa après les autres
pour vous dire ce que j'en pense dans le
domaine de la SCP je dirais demain et
les groupes s'expr là-dessus en toute
liberté c'est un sujet qui n'est pas
venu à l'Assemblée nationale vous me
direz qu'il y en a eu beaucoup qui sont
pas venus
regardez assez peu d'articles même si
c'était une discussion d'épiciers vu
qu'on parlait de tout en même temps et
de tout les articles en même temps mais
le Sénat a repris les choses un peu plus
sérieusement de façon il faut dire que
c'est pas la même composition politique
non plus et donc dans la composition
politique du Sénat le travail a été
heureusement bien fait et il y a cette
proposition qui a été votée par le Sénat
qui est beaucoup porté je pense par le
rapporteur ne nous en discuterons
évidemment
sur l'équilibre financier puisque c'est
quelque chose auquel vous êtes
évidemment très attaché Olivier dussobe
dit déjà il va manquer 300 à 400
millions en 2030 est-ce que pour vous
c'est grave ou est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'il va falloir faire une réforme une
autre réforme de la prochaine fois
équilibrée il faut que le texte quand il
est présenté sérieusement avec des puces
et des moins il doit être le plus
équilibré possible il faut trouver les
solutions d'économie de des solutions
dans le temps aussi vous pouvez vous
pouvez aussi regarder ce qui va se
passer en 2024 2025 2026 2027 dans voilà
il va se passer un certain nombre de
choses et donc nous devons regarder en
fait il y a une dynamique dans
l'équilibre qui va se recréer en 2030 à
partir du texte voté donc on peut
rediscuter de cette dynamique mais nous
devons évidemment présenter en français
un régime de retraite
équilibré à 2030 puisque c'est
l'objectif de la loi l'une des solutions
proposées par Bruno notailler alors
qu'il sera pas discuté demain puisque ça
a été retiré c'était d'accélérer la
suppression des régimes spéciaux vous
étiez favorable vous
moi j'ai déposé des amendements dans
d'autres réformes des retraites
là-dessus je pense que c'est évidemment
très long la convergence est évidemment
très très long puisque ce sont les
nouveaux entrants qui rentrent au régime
général et pas et pas les personnes qui
sont en on aurait pu
réfléchir à cela bon je il y a aussi un
pragmatisme à réalisme les syndicats
sont arc-boutés les régimes spéciaux
aussi donc ça n'a pas été fait le
gouvernement de la pas fait je pense que
c'est difficile
non c'est pas un manque de courage c'est
c'est du réalisme du réalisme politique
Nicolas Sarkozy Xavier Bertrand ne
l'avait pas fait non plus en 2000 en
2010 lorsque on a réformé les régimes
spéciaux on n'a pas on n'a pas mis les
régimes spéciaux en extinction il faut
les mettre en extinction ça prendra
évidemment du temps donc je suis pas
opposé aux principes que défendaient
Bruno Retailleau mais là c'était c'était
pas possible et d'ailleurs n'a pas n'a
pas défendu cet amendement au cours des
débats on a vu le gouvernement tentait
de faire passer un amendement au Sénat
sur un retour à une réforme systémique
le régime universel vous y seriez
favorable ou personnellement
non moi j'y suis pas vraiment favorable
parce que comment vous expliquez cette
cette tentative ou cette tentation de
faire revenir le sujet du régime
universel ça revient toujours parce que
au fond lorsque on discute d'un régime
universel on parle immédiatement de
paramètres et lorsqu'on parle de
paramètres on parle immédiatement d'un
régime universel donc il faut trouver un
écart entre les deux quelque chose de il
faut être efficace les paramètres ils
sont évidemment très efficaces et
paramètres c'est très très politique qui
peut penser que la fixation de l'âge
n'est pas politique honnêtement
qu'est-ce qu'on vit actuellement donc
les paramètres ça veut dire que les gens
nous compatriotes il se projettent tout
de suite individuellement dedans parce
que c'est pas compliqué à comprendre
donc c'est c'est enfin c'est c'est
extrêmement précis c'est aussi au fond
très très démocratique parce que chacun
peut donner son opinion en général les
gens sont contre mais au fond c'est elle
est quand même la nécessité un universel
c'est une confusion générale c'est très
bien sur le papier mais alors il faut 20
ans 30 ans de convergence pour aboutir
de la situation à la situation B pour
arriver à la situation c'est de
convergence et puis c'est assez logique
et des différences selon différentes
professions ou
voilà c'est logique la vie et les
retraites c'est quand même enfin les
retraites c'est quand même le reflet
d'une vie et donc il y a des situations
extrêmement différentes il y a des gens
qui sont autonomes qui demandent à rien
à personne qui on aurait pu avoir une
sorte de régime de base très universelle
et puis après des régimes
complémentaires prenant en compte des
différences bon écoutez ça c'est
derrière nous
voilà mais on peut toujours continuer en
discuter puis peut-être qu'un jour la
France
engagera un système très très très très
long de convergence des choses
aujourd'hui c'est pas là c'est la
sauvegarde du régime de retraite et
c'est par le travail par le travail au
fond par l'augmentation du travail la
gauche souhaite que la Commission
mixparitaire de demain soit rendue
publique qu'en pensez-vous
mais ils sont totalement dans la
communication la nupesse et les filles
le Parti socialiste mais c'est la même
chose maintenant le Parti socialiste et
les filles il y a plus beaucoup de
différences idéologiques et là grignoter
et avaler le Parti socialiste au moins
l'Assemblée nationale pour ceux qui leur
reste et c'est toujours lui
j'ai jamais le Parti socialiste à poser
des questions sur quand il était au
gouvernement sur les commissions mixtes
paritaire il y en a eu des milliers
depuis depuis la 5ème le début de la 5e
République et c'est une bonne manière de
faire c'est pourquoi pourquoi c'est pas
un public pourquoi il y a pas des
caméras partout parce que c'est la
sérénité des débats parce que ça permet
à un moment donné de regarder
objectivement les choses essayer de
trouver dans un déballons parfois très
long ce sera peut-être très long des
deux bons compromis des compromis actifs
positifs donc tout ça sous la pression
des caméras d'un public on voit bien que
ça donnera l'Assemblée nationale ça
donnera l'Assemblée nationale d'empêcher
le négociations d'aboutir
eux ils veulent empêcher les
négociations d'aboutir donc des
propositions c'est des propositions
c'est des propositions tout à fait
inacceptables du groupe la France
insoumise à l'Assemblée disait hier soir
sur notre antenne que si elle est pas
rendue publique elle et son collègue de
la France insoumise raconteront en
direct sur les réseaux sociaux ce qui se
passe au sein de Laurent évidemment pas
le droit de le faire il faut qu'il se
conforme sinon il faut qu'il fasse autre
chose et puis madame panneau comme
d'autres ils sont accro des réseaux
sociaux ils ne peuvent plus vivre quand
ils veulent sans arrêt voir leur image
dans ses réseaux sociaux là ils ont des
autisme totalement dingue donc ils sont
tous là ils sont tous là avec leur
téléphone portable ils n'ont pas le
droit dans l'hémicycle mais quand même
de temps en temps ils font en train de
se filmer ou de se faire filmer en train
de parler tout le temps tout le temps
oui mais ils en ont fait eux-mêmes une
culture ils existent par cela ils
existent pas par leurs idées ils sont à
peu près égales à zéro ils existent
uniquement par l'image qu'ils ont envie
de donner et c'est une image de
polémique c'est une image extrêmement
divisante
mais vous comment comment ça va se
passer c'est à dire qu'elle n'aura pas
son téléphone portable vous l'en
empêcher
qu'est-ce qui va se passer
des règles de règlement il y a des
règles comme partout de voilà je suis
pas assis au milieu de la table en train
de vous répondre il y a une règle je
vais être assis je la respecte voilà
chacun respectera les mêmes règles sinon
on peut pas travailler sinon même
panneau elle ira faire autre chose ok
d'accord il y aura un vote à l'Assemblée
nationale jeudi après-midi est-ce que
pour vous le 49-3 est inéluctable pas du
tout ah non non pas du tout je pense que
le je pense que on peut on peut espérer
et j'ai le bon espoir que qui a un vote
et donc une capacité à faire en sorte
que puisque la vraie question c'est sur
les républicains que la républicains
puissent voter largement alors tout le
monde le votera pas comme d'ailleurs
dans la majorité il y a quelques-uns au
sein de la majorité vous êtes sûr de
faire le plein des voix bah non on n'est
jamais sûr de faire le plein
pourcentage des députés c'est le
pourcentage des députés le gros du
problème c'est chez LR si chez LR
puisque on nous annonce parfois un tiers
de députés de votant pas sur
intéressante une vingtaine de personnes
aussi exactement mais donc c'est tout à
fait
jamais à 100% sinon ce serait d'ailleurs
assez c'est tout nouveau
de la majorité présidentielle de
renaissance d'horizon je m'intéresse pas
à la discipline dans dans les parties de
la majorité ce qui m'intéresse c'est que
c'est 99% ou 97 % des gens votent vote
et Soustra évidemment le cas dans la
majorité il faut que les républicains
votent en large majorité en ce qui
concerne leurs propres groupes ils sont
à l'Assemblée c'est pas la question
vraiment du Sénat c'est la question de
l'Assemblée qu'elle a semblée il puisse
ils sont 61 ou quelque chose comme ça il
faut qu'il vote évidemment très
largement j'espère que ce sera le cas
mais mais je vois qu'il y a des
agitations il y a les camarades de
Monsieur Pradier enfin il y en a très
peu ils sont très peu nombreux après il
y a tous ceux qui veulent soutenir leur
envoiier qui ne veulent pas voter leur
invoquer
visiblement ne veut pas de ce texte
parce que si vous voulez être ce texte
j'ai connu alors ok plus actif même si
vous voulez être ce texte probablement
il leur demanderait de le voter c'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui donc on voit bien
qu'autour de la réforme des retraites ça
devient un terrible alibi pour un
certain nombre de gens qui veulent
prendre le pouvoir au sein des
républicains c'est pas à la hauteur de
l'enjeu l'enjeu il dépasse tout ça c'est
pas de la petite politique au sein des
républicains ça c'est pas vraiment le
problème de la réforme des traitement le
problème des des sujets internes des
sujets d'ambition personnelle de
projection personnelle vers le déjà les
élections de 2000 27 c'est tout cela il
faut dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont et ça au détriment d'une réforme
que les républicains aurait fait
eux-mêmes eux-mêmes s'il y avait un
écart très fort si c'était évidemment un
sujet mais la vérité c'est que tout
porte à croire que les républicains s'il
les républicains avaient été au poids
aurait déposés une réforme de même
nature peut-être même plus dur puisque
la plupart des candidats la primaire
demandaient 65 ans et que moi j'étais
d'ailleurs favorable à cela Xavier
Bertrand y compris on voit bien que
c'est un combat ailleurs autrement assez
irrationnel d'utilisation à des fins
personnelles d'un texte dont l'intérêt
général et pourtant prédominant enfin
dominant surplombant sur plancton alors
attendez est-ce que si c'est un problème
de de c'est un problème interne
républicain et qu'on est dans quelque
chose d'irrationnel vous êtes en train
de nous dire que quel que soit le
contenu de la CMP et du texte final ça
ne changera rien je peux mais je pense
que la rationalité peut gagner je pense
la majorité la plus de la majorité du
groupe républicain l'Assemblée nationale
est favorable à ce texte
Eric cedi Olivier Marley avec son fait
un travail difficile c'est difficile
parce qu'ils saute évidemment dans
l'opposition personne ne leur demande
d'adhérer la majorité moi j'ai adhéré à
la majorité parce que je considérais que
les républicaines étaient dans une
impasse idéologique
inverse et je la respecte
comment on fait pour les convaincre de
voter le texte le dernier de temps en
temps le bon sens reprend ses droits
le président de la République et que on
se dit que ce serait bien que Monsieur
Wauquiez que Monsieur Bertrand il soit
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
représente une alternative ce qui ne
sera pas le cas mais représente une
alternative et ben
je ils peuvent à un moment donné se dire
attends je vote sur quoi je vote sur la
garantie d'un système de retraite sur
les 10 prochaines années et si on ne le
fait pas personne ne le fera ou si on le
fait dans deux ans dans trois ans dans
quatre ans dans les mêmes conditions on
le fera de façon bien plus difficile
parce que les seuils de notamment
déficit seront bien plus élevés mais
excusez-moi si le choix se fait dans
l'isoloir comme on dit ça veut dire
qu'il faudrait peut-être quand même
préparer un carreau
ça se fait et ça se fait ça se fait
nominativement donc donc les quand même
je pense qu'il y a certaines de gens qui
n'auront pas peur de leur
circonscription parce que il y a tous
ceux qui ont très très peur de leur
circonscription donc bah ceux-là ils ont
peur de tout donc ils n'auront pas peur
de leur circonscription il y a des gens
qui qui réellement seront à la hauteur
de l'enjeu quoi se diront ok je suis pas
macroniste pour autant je n'adhère pas
la majorité mais je vote ce texte parce
que ce texte ça aurait pu être le mien
est-ce que vous redoutez une notion de
censure qui pourrait être soutenu par
certains élèves pas du tout je je je
crois pas du tout si jamais on était
dans ce cas-là je n'en sais rien je ne
vois pas du tout à ce moment-là elle est
allé voter une motion de censure en tout
cas ce sera jamais le cas pour ni pour
le président de LR ni pour le président
du groupe qui tous ceux qui l'entourent
qui sont quand même heureusement bien
plus nombreux que ceux qui contestent
cette cette réforme à tort ils se
conteste le même en contestant cette
réforme ils se conteste même ils
conteste leurs histoires ils comptent
quand est-ce leur histoire comment
peut-on un moment donné construire un
avenir quand on commence à contester sa
propre histoire un dernier mot puisque
Laurent Berger le secrétaire général de
la CFDT annonce ce matin sur RTL qu'il
lira avec les leaders syndicaux
manifestés jeudi après-midi devant
l'Assemblée nationale qu'en pensez-vous
il peut manifester où il veut la CMP
sera l'Assemblée nationale et il ira
le rôle des partenaires sociaux ce sera
aussi dans le rôle des partenaires
sociaux à un moment donné de dire que la
démocratie politique elle a un moment
donné voté ce texte ce texte il existe
et que et qu'à ce moment-là et bien
voilà le combat doit cesser puisque le
texte démocratiquement existe la
démocratie politique elle domine la
démocratie entre guillemets de la rue
merci beaucoup merci
de défi à 500 jours des Jeux merci
beaucoup Stéphane